abone ol
Allah aşkına davasına ben
bir yaşam çok hızlı bir şekilde
dönüşüyor Hepimiz bir yerden başlıyoruz
bir yere doğru gidiyoruz doğduğunuz ülke
aileniz Bulunduğunuz çevrede ki
faktörler her biri Aslında Gideceğiniz
nasıl şekillendirecek Sizde ilgili biraz
ipucu katıyor hayat bu süreçte Benim de
yaşamım oldukça büyük bir dönüşümle süre
geldi hayatım boyunca her zaman 30
yıllık yaşamı boyunca keşfetmek odaklı
İnsanları doğayı bilimi sanatı
keşfetmekte hayatımızı Çünkü bu süreçte
dört buçuk yaşında
Şu ana okuluna giderken öndeki araçların
plakasındaki dört haneli rakamların
yerlerini değiştirip onları tekrar
okuyordum ailem bir farklılık olduğunu
hissetmişti ilkokula başladım matematik
sınavında çıkan soruları yazılı sınavda
soruyu okuyordum sonucu rakamla
yazıyordum genelde Hani gidiş yolunu
puan verir öğrencilere Fakat benim için
bir yol yoktu yani bu çocuğun gidiyor
herhalde yol değil diye düşünmeye
başladılar ve sonrasında bir aykü testi
yapıldı ve sonuç 143 çıktı eğitim Civan
ailem biraz etmiş herhalde biraz kaygan
the ama mutlulardı mutlulardı ve
başarılar süre geldiyse Kozan'da
İzmir'de yaşıyorum İzmir birinciliği
elde etmiştim çok çok sayıda 16 yaşıma
geldim onu taşıma geldiği zaman herkes
çok iyi bir sayısalcıyım o dönemde babam
özellikle
en iyi bir sayısalcı olarak çok dahi Bir
doktor olduğunu Hayal ediyordu Ben de
bunu istiyordum Sonuçta sınav sistemi
değişti Ben sayısaldan eşit ağırlığa
geçtim ve bu süreçte de üniversiteye
yerleştim ve İstanbul'a taşındım şimdi
sıfırdan yeni bir hayat kuruyorsunuz
ayrı mı uzakta yeniliklerimiz var her
şeyi sıfırdan yapıyorsunuz üniversiteye
girdim Bir sınıfta Kağıt göğüs ismini
bir ders oluyordu bildiğiniz matematik
dersi eski Matematik Olimpiyatları
birincisi olarak 100 üzerinden 10 puan
aldım sonra hocaya gittim hocam dedim
beni böyle bir geçmişim var dedi Senin
aldık bir yere gitmemiş Korkma o ikiye
dönmeye başlamış biraz atamıyordu beni
bak at Ben hayatımda ciddi bir dönüşüm
yapma ihtiyacı olduğunu hissettim o gün
Sen ne yaptın akademik Kariyerim çok iyi
olmayacağını anladım gerçekten çok
önemli bu arada akademik kalıyor Ama
kendimi kulüpler hobiler ve iş hayatı
stajlar derken ve farklı bir şekilde
geliştirmeye başladım alt dönemlere
böyle abilik yapmaya çalışıyordum İş
hayatına başladım Şu anda çalıştığım
şirkette ilk yöneticim baktığın yaşından
büyük laflar ediyorsun Sana bundan sonra
Benjamin Button diyeceğim dedi peki
dedim sana mentörlük yapacağım seni
farklı bir noktaya taşıyacağım Çünkü şu
an çalıştığım bölüme çok uygun değilsin
dedi
ve o da tamam dedim o süreçte çok fazla
şey öğrendim 26 yaşıma geldiğim zaman
yani bunları yaklaşık altı yıl önce
mezun olduğu üniversiteden Hocam beni
aradı Burak dedi sana çok benzettiğim
bir arkadaşım var hayatta zorluklarla
geçmiş ama potansiyeli çok yüksek ona
bir tanışırsan bir destek olursan çok
sevinirim İyi bir kariyeri olabilir ama
yanlış gönderdim dirsek yanlış yollarda
gidebilir dedi mi peki dedim arkadaşımla
konuşmaya başladım ben kendimi tanıttı
Sana nasıl yardımcı olabilirim
sen bana ilk söyle şey şuydu benim
hayatım çok zorluklarla geçti Her zaman
ailecek büyük zorluklarla atlattık Ben
artık kaybeden kişi olmak istemiyorum
Kesinlikle ve hep kazanmak istiyorum
dedi dedim Öyle bir şey yok hayatta
şimdi kazanmak Neye göre kime göre hangi
durumda oldukça farklı şekillerde
boyutları olan bir kavram önce dedim bu
kaygı Umuda dönüştürmeliyiz dedim Çünkü
sen şu anda kaygısı hepimizin acilleri
kaygılı bu çocuk okuyacak mı Nereye
gidecek nasıl bir hayat olacak ama bunu
Umuda dönüşenler hayatta gerçek başarıya
ulaşıyor Bununla ilgili bir bilimsel
çalışma var 1957 Amerikalı psikoloji
uzmanı doktoru sırtı yok ki
ama bazı insanlar umutlu olan insanlar
hayatta daha fazla başarılı olabilir
Daha fazla kazanabilir diyor ben bunu
kanıtlayacağım mm çalışmaya başlıyorlar
bir kaç fare ile deney yapıyorlar Fatih
suyu atıyorlar suda birkaç dakika da
yanıyor bazıları bazıları 15-20 dakika
da yok demek ki doğal dayanma süreçleri
arasında insanlar arasında farklar
oluşabilir sonrasında tam ölmek
üzereyken çıkartıyor fareleri kuruluyor
bunları ve tekrar suya koyuyor Fareler
öğreniyor Demek ki bu bir son değil Bizi
kurtaracaklar iki dakika dayanan fare 10
dakikada yanmaya başlıyor 60 saate kadar
dayanan Fareler oluyor Hangimizin hayatı
böyle değil ki Hepimiz bazen Hiç
bilmediğim suları atlamak zorunda
kalıyoruz başkaları bize atabiliyor ama
Umut olduğu zaman oradan kurtulacağınızı
bildiğiniz zaman
iyi sonuç gerçekten kusursuz oluyor
kazanmak demişti arkadaşım dedim ki
kazanmak için önce şuna dikkat etmelisin
bir plan olmalı geleceği çok çok iyi
hazırlan malısın Çünkü artık en iyi
çalışan en çok çalışan başarıyor
hazırlık sürecini güzel tamamladıktan
sonra da sabırla kazanacağım günü
kazanacağın anları kızılcan insanları
beklemelisin dedim Çünkü kariyer
dediğimiz şey şu beyaz
sağ alt tabanını their Stay gibi bu
beyaz taban sizin hayatta
biriktirdiğiniz yetkinlikleriniz
uzmanlıklarını zil işim ahını iyi
özellikleriniz sarı dikey ise bir yandan
ve Bir Fidan Gibi bir Filiz gibi çıkıp
yükseldiği Nizza gösteriyor O nedenle bu
beyaz kısım ne kadar küçük olursa siz
bir şekilde yükselebilirsin zaman ilk
rüzgarda yıkılırsın
var ama tabanını temiz çok sağlam olursa
Ama mutlaka Filizlenmiş Siz yine
yükselir siniz ama yıkılmaz her şeye
dayanabilirsin verdiğim tavsiye buldu ve
bu tabanı en iyi dolduracak 5 bir reçete
sunum arkadaşıma sağlık alışkanlık değer
sabır ve ilik kısaca bunlara değineceğim
zty sağlık altında her şeyin temel yani
sağlığınız yoksa yoksunuz Bu gerçekten
tartışmayı gerektirmeyen bir konu Fakat
hayatı sevmek gerçekten sağlığınıza
doğal etkisi var O nedenle pozitif
insanlar çok daha fazla ve güzel
yaşıyorlar İnsanları sevmek gerçekten
çok önemli bir de işini Sevmek eğer
mutlu bir işiniz varsa hayatını
sürdürecek kaynaklarınızı oluştuğu için
çok güzel bir şekilde hayatımızı idame
ettirebiliyor sunuz alışkanlıklar
gerçekten hayatımızı şekillendiriyor ve
birer bir kitabın kapağı gibi sizin
alışkanlıklarını Sizin kapağınızı oluyor
iyi alışkanlıklarınıza kötü
alışkanlıklarınızdan da metalik yaptığım
arkadaşımın kötü bir alışkanlığı vardır
sigara içiyordu ben de o dönemde Sen ise
oynuyordum yoğun bir şekilde Sen ise iki
kural vardır bir Kendinizden kötülerle
oynayacaksınız birilerine içeceksiniz ki
tenis oyuncak kişi bulabilirsiniz iki
kendinize insan iyilerle oyuncaksız
kendinizi geliştirebilir
ya Ben mentörlük sensoren tenis kortunda
ayarlamıştım arkadaşımı oynuyorduk çok
sevdi sporcu bir kimliği vardı ama spor
yapmıyordu bu vesileyle sigarayı bıraktı
sigarayı bıraktığı için dönüp dolaşıp
yine tenis kortlarının zaman geçirirken
bir şirkette direktör olarak çalışan
biri ile tanıştı o vesileyle işe kabul
oldu sonrasında yurtdışına giderken şu
an çok iyi bir kariyer var bu süreçte
iyi alışkanlıklar bizim başarı motorumuz
kötü detaylara bağımlı olmaktansa
Aslında bağımlı olmamak gerçekten çok
önemli bağımlı olduğumuz zaman sizi
geriye çekiyor yavaşlatıyor sonrasında
verdi 3. tavsiye şu oldu hayatta ne
yaparsan yap yeni bir değer kat ve Sahip
olduğunuz herşeyi çok değer ver Çünkü
Maddi manevi sevdiğiniz insanlar aileniz
Doğa Bunlar bizim değerimiz bunları bir
değer vermek için iki Bugün her
bu izleyebilir herkes üniversitede
okuyor Herkesin bir yerlerde tanıdığı
var Herkes çok güzel oldu ama yeni bir
fark yaratan kişiler her zaman öne
çıkıyor Ben şu an çalıştığım şekilde ilk
Başladığım zaman 3 yıldır aynı şekilde
yapılan basit bir raporu formunu
değiştirmiştim yeni bir noktaya
taşınmıştım ve bu benim kariyerimde
gerçekten en önemli aşamalardan biri ne
vesile olan küçük bir detaylı O yüzden
küçük detaylardan değer yaratmak
gerçekten çok önemli Hayat her zaman çok
kolay değil arkadaşlar önemli tavsiyem
bu Belki de sabırlı olmak çok kötü zor
zamanlar geçici Hayat gerçekten zor ama
güzelliklerini odaklanmak ve zor anlarda
biraz sabırlı olduğum zaman gerçekten
sen iyi günler için mücadeleye devam
edebiliyoruz ve Benim için en önemli
başlık ilk bugün nasıl bir başarısız
olursa olsun ne yaparsanız yapın
çok iyi bir insan değilsiniz hiçbir
değeri yok benim gözümde çok değer
verdiğim iş insanlardan büyüklerimize
söyledikleri bunlar
ki bu dünyadan hepimiz geçeceğiz
geçerken arkamızdan ne kadar çok kişi
iyi bilirdik derse kalpten Bence bu
hayatta yapabileceğimiz başarı çiçeğimiz
en önemli şeylerden bir tanesi ondan
arkadaşıma dedim ki iyiliğine güvenmek
iyi olduğuna güvenmek en önemli başarın
olsun hayatta her zaman İyiler kazanmaya
bilir ama en güzel uyku User sürer
teşekkürler